This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the Hick TV show Breaking Bad, high school chemistry teacher Walter White learns he is dying from cancer. To make money for his cancer treatments, for his family, he uses his chemistry expertise to start manufacturing crystal meth. When his wife's skyler finds out he's been selling drugs, she is appalled. In an effort to win her back, Walter asks her to see things from his point of view. I've done a terrible thing, but I did it for a good reason. I did it for us. Walter thinks of himself as a good person, a good husband, a good father.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。在热门美剧《绝命毒师》中，高中化学教师沃尔特·怀特得知自己患上了晚期癌症。为了给自己的癌症治疗和家人赚钱，他利用自己的化学专业知识开始制造冰毒。当他的妻子斯凯勒发现他一直在贩毒时，她震惊不已。为了重新赢得她的理解，沃尔特请求她从他的角度看待问题。我做了一件可怕的事，但我这么做是有充分理由的。我这么做是为了我们。沃尔特认为自己是个好人、好丈夫、好父亲。
He believes that the money he gets from manufacturing drugs will keep a roof over his family's heads once he dies. But as Walter gets sucked into the underworld of crime and illicit drugs, he starts to commit acts of violence in order to keep the money coming. The deeper he goes, the more rationalizations he invents. he goes, the more rationalizations he invents. Breaking bad won a raft of awards, season after season. I personally think of it as the greatest TV show ever made. What makes the story so powerful is that even though the plot is improbable, it has the ring
他相信，通过制造毒品赚来的钱能在自己去世后让家人有个遮风挡雨的地方。但随着沃尔特一步步陷入犯罪和毒品的地下世界，为了源源不断地赚钱，他开始做出暴力行为。他陷得越深，编造的借口就越多。他陷得越深，编造的借口就越多。《绝命毒师》一季又一季地斩获了大量奖项。我个人认为它是史上最伟大的电视剧。这个故事之所以如此引人入胜，是因为尽管情节不太可能发生，但它却带有
of psychological truth. All of us tell ourselves stories about why we do the things we do. We explain our flaws and failures, and we come up with plausible explanations for our actions. Today on the show, the first episode of a two-part series into the human capacity for self-justification. It's also the story of a researcher who has studied the phenomenon for nearly three-quarters of a century. He has explored the psychology of rationalization and the many ways it ends up being used for evil,
心理上的真实感。我们所有人都会对自己讲述各种故事，来解释我们为什么要做出某些行为。我们为自己的缺点和失败寻找借口，并为自己的行动编造看似合理的解释。今天的节目是一系列两集关于人类自我合理化能力的探究的第一集。这也是一个关于一位研究这一现象近四分之三个世纪的学者的故事。他探索了合理化的心理机制，以及它最终被用于恶意的种种方式，
but also the curious ways it can be used for good. How we explain our actions to ourselves this week on Hidden Brain. I was a very shy little kid and I was overshadowed by my older brother, Jason, who was a star. Growing up, Elliot Aronson loved his brother, Jason. But Elliot often found himself unnoticed, what his brother got all the attention. He was two and a half years older than I, and whenever we went to a family gathering,
同时也探索了它如何被用于善意的奇妙方式。我们如何向自己解释我们的行为，本周《隐藏的大脑》。我小时候是个非常害羞的小孩，而且我一直被优秀的哥哥杰森的光芒所掩盖。在成长过程中，埃利奥特·阿伦森非常爱他的哥哥杰森。但埃利奥特经常发现自己被忽视，而他的哥哥却得到了所有的关注。他比我大两岁半，每当我们去参加家庭聚会时，
all my aunts and uncles say, hey, here's Jason. And they were all excited about Jason. And then I'd say, oh, hi, Elliot. Billy Batson and his mentor travel the highways and byways of the land on a never ending mission. One time, Elliot saw a movie about a shy kid who was transformed into the superhero, Captain Marvel.
我所有的阿姨和叔叔都会说，嘿，杰森来了。他们对杰森都兴奋不已。然后他们会说，哦，嗨，埃利奥特。比利·巴特森和他的导师在大陆的高速公路和小路上执行着一项永无止境的任务。有一次，埃利奥特看了一部电影，讲的是一个害羞的小男孩变身成了超级英雄“惊奇队长”。
And I immediately went home and tried to towel around my neck as if it were a cape. There's someone awesome forces at the utter end of a single word. And I got up onto my porch which was about four feet off the ground. I stretched out my arm and I said shazam which transformed Billy Batson, this meek little kid into Captain Marvel, the strong Avenger and I said shazam and I leaped off the porch and I landed badly and sprained my ankle. That was a story, that was a signature story that captures how I was as a little kid. Elliot didn't realize it at the time, but it was an early example of his own capacity
我立刻跑回家，试图把一条毛巾围在脖子上当成披风。单一词汇的极端尽头存在着某种令人敬畏的力量。我爬上了大约离地四英尺的门廊。我伸出胳膊说“沙赞”，这把比利·巴特森这个温顺的小男孩变成了惊奇队长——那个强壮的复仇者。我说“沙赞”，然后从门廊上跳了下去，结果落地没做好，扭伤了脚踝。那是个故事，那是一个标志性的故事，捕捉了我小时候的性格。埃利奥特当时并没有意识到，但这是他自身能力的一个早期例证——
to tell himself a story and believe it. Some time later, he came by a more serious example. Elliot and his family lived in a town outside Boston. Elliot and his family lived in a town outside Boston. We were just about the only Jewish family in a very lently anti-Semitic neighborhood. This was in the late 1930s, early 1940s. I had to go to Hebrew school when I was nine years old and walking home from Hebrew school in the dark.
那就是对自己讲述一个故事并深信不疑。一段时间后，他遇到了一个更严肃的例子。埃利奥特和他的家人住在波士顿郊外的一个小镇上。埃利奥特和他的家人住在波士顿郊外的一个小镇上。我们几乎是那个极其排犹的社区里唯一的犹太家庭。那是20世纪30年代末、40年代初。我九岁时必须去上希伯来语学校，天黑后步行回家时，
Frequently, I was waylaid by gangs of teenagers. Mostly, they simply shouted anti-Semitic things at me, called me a dirty Jew, and I didn't think I was particularly dirty. I didn't understand it. And sometimes they pushed me around a little. Every once in a while, they really beat me up. And one of my vivid memories was after one of these drawings sitting on a curb stone,
我经常遭到成群结队的青少年的伏击。大多时候，他们只是对我大喊反犹太的话，叫我肮脏的犹太人，而我并不觉得自己特别脏。我不理解这是为什么。有时他们还会推搡我一下。每隔一段时间，他们真的会痛打我一顿。我记忆犹新的一幕是，在经历过这样一番殴打后，我坐在路边石上，
nursing a bloody nose and a split lip, and wondering why these kids hated me so much when they didn't even know me. But in time, when Elliott was the same age as his tormentors, he found himself behaving in a way that his younger self would have found incomprehensible. You know, in junior high school when kids are beginning to flex their muscles, I was sort of in the center of the pack.
处理着流血的鼻子和破裂的嘴唇，纳闷为什么这些甚至根本不认识我的人会这么恨我。但后来，当埃利奥特长到和那些折磨他的人一样大时，他发现自己的行为方式让年幼时的自己根本无法理解。你知道，在初中时，当孩子们开始展现肌肉时，我差不多处在群体中心。
I was a pretty good student. I was a pretty good athlete. And then there were kids at the lower end who were often bullied by kids at the high end. And I remember joining in the bullying, in the taunting, in the teasing, in the pushing around of the kids at the low end. And I remember really clearly feeling at the time, I want to identify with the better group, with the group that was more popular, more athletic, and not with the lower group, I want to make sure that they didn't include me with the group that was being bullied. So, I joined in the bullying, much to my regret later when I thought about that. I wish I had been the kind of kid at age 13 or
我是一个相当不错的学生。我是一个相当不错的运动员。然后，有些处在底端、经常被顶端孩子欺负的孩子。我记得自己也加入了霸凌、嘲弄、取笑和推搡底层孩子的行列。我清楚地记得当时的感觉：我想认同更好的那个群体、那个更受欢迎、更有运动天赋的群体，而不是底层群体；我想确保他们不会把我归入被霸凌的群体中。所以，我加入了霸凌，后来每当想起这件事，我都深感后悔。我希望自己在13岁或
14 who would have stood up for the smaller kids, the kids with the glasses, the kids who were the target of intents bullying, but instead I joined in because I wanted the kids at the top of the hierarchy to think I was one of them rather than one of those guys at the bottom of the hierarchy. When Elliot tied a cape around his neck and jumped off the back porch as a little kid, the consequences of his self-justifications were experienced by Elliot himself. His aching ankle told him that he was not in fact Captain Marvel. But when he bullied children who were weaker and told himself that he was doing it to keep from being bullied himself, this rationalization had real victims.
14岁时能成为那种为较小的孩子、戴眼镜的孩子、遭受严重霸凌的目标挺身而出的孩子，但相反，我加入了进去，因为我想让金字塔顶端的孩子们认为我是他们中的一员，而不是金字塔底端的那些家伙。当埃利奥特还是个小男孩时，把披风系在脖子上从后廊跳下去，其自我合理化的后果是由埃利奥特本人承担的。他隐隐作痛的脚踝告诉他，他实际上并不是惊奇队长。但是，当他霸凌比他弱小的儿童，并告诉自己他这么做是为了防止自己被霸凌时，这种合理化却产生了真正的受害者。
At home, Elliot saw another form of self-justification play out in the actions and words of his father. As I remember him, he was a tough guy who grew up on the streets of Boston. He was uneducated. I think he had only a sixth or seventh grade education, and he began his life as selling socks and underwear from a push cart. That's how he earned his living when he was a teenager, and he later graduated to owning a small, dragwood store where he sold socks and underwear from behind a counter.
在家里，埃利奥特在父亲的言行中看到了另一种形式的自我合理化。在我印象中，他是个在波士顿街头长大的硬汉。他没受过什么教育。我想他大概只有六年级或七年级的文化水平，他以推着手推车卖袜子和内衣开始了自己的生活。这就是他十几岁时的谋生方式，后来他升格拥有一家小型干杂货店，在柜台后面卖袜子和内衣。
And during the Great Depression, he lost his stores. The The The The The The The The The The The The
在大萧条时期，他失去了店铺。The The The The The The The The The The The The
The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The
The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The the The the The The the The The the the The the The The The the The The the The The the The The The He would be standing on the corner with a bunch of guys and he would bet on how many cars would pass through that intersection in a five minute period. Wow.
The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The The the The the The The the The The the the The the The The The the The The the The The the The The The 他会和一群人在街角站着，赌在五分钟内会有多少辆车通过那个路口。哇。
He was a gambler, which was okay when he had a little money, but during the Great Depression, when he lost his stores and he kept on gambling with whatever money he had left. We were extremely poor. How did that affect you and the family? I mean, of course, just the circumstances you're describing sound really, really rough. But did anyone in the family question what he was doing? Did he justify to himself his own behavior and if so, how? Well, my mother questioned it, of course, and Wow. Well, my mother questioned it, of course, and I think my mother felt that he lost his stores because of his gambling. She felt that he wasn't a good businessman, that he was too busy having fun and losing money on gambling.
他是个赌徒，这在他有点钱的时候还可以接受，但在大萧条时期，他失去了店铺，却依然用身上仅剩的钱继续赌博。我们极其穷困。这如何影响了你和你的家庭？我的意思是，当然，你所描述的处境听起来真的很艰难。但家里有人质疑他在做什么吗？他是否向自己为自己的行为辩解？如果是的话，是怎么辩解的？嗯，我母亲当然质疑过，而且哇。嗯，我母亲当然质疑过，而且我认为我母亲觉得他失去店铺是因为赌博。她觉得他不是个好商人，他太忙于享乐并在赌博中输光了钱。
In the one serious conversation I had with my father about it, when I was about 14 or 15 years old. He said, you know, your mother blames me for the great depression, but everybody lost their jobs then. And I lost my stories because we were living in a poor neighborhood, and my customers were poor people, and they were unemployed. And of course I extended them credit. Your mother, he said, faulted me for that, but those were my only customers. If I couldn't extend them credit, I couldn't do any business at all.
在我与父亲关于这件事的唯一一次严肃谈话中，那是我大约14、15岁的时候。他说，你知道，你母亲把大萧条归咎于我，但当时所有人都失去了工作。我失去店铺是因为我们住在一个贫困社区，我的顾客都是穷人，他们都失业了。我当然向他们提供赊账。他说，你母亲因此责备我，但那些是我唯一的顾客。如果我不能向他们提供赊账，我就根本无法做生意。
I extended them credit and of course they weren't able to pay me back and that's how we lost the stores, not because of my gambling, he said, but because of the great depression. Eliot's father didn't think he was a bad businessman. He didn't think he had a gambling problem. To him, the false lay in the Great Depression. In time, Elliot was to help discover the psychological mechanisms for the stories we tell ourselves. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
我向他们提供赊账，他们当然无力还钱，我们就是这样失去了店铺，他说，这不是因为我的赌博，而是因为大萧条。埃利奥特的父亲不认为自己是个糟糕的商人。他不认为自己有赌博问题。在他看来，错误在于大萧条。假以时日，埃利奥特将协助发现我们讲述的故事背后的心理机制。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. As a kid, Elliot Aronson had noticed how both he and the people around him would justify their own actions to themselves. He had no thought of becoming a psychologist, even though the questions that sometimes went through his head were questions at the heart of psychology. When he got beaten up for being Jewish, for example,
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。小时候，埃利奥特·阿伦森就注意到，他和周围的人是如何向自己为自己的行为辩解的。他从未想过成为一名心理学家，尽管有时掠过他脑海的问题正是心理学核心的问题。例如，当他因为犹太人身份而被殴打时，
I think I was nine years old at the time. I thought it to wonder if they got to know me better and realized what a sweet and charming little boy I was, would they like me more? And then wondering, hey, if they liked me more, would that make them maybe hate other Jews less? I didn't realize it at the time, but of course these are profound social psychological questions. At Brandeis University, Eliot decided to major in economics. It was the 1950s, but the depression years of his childhood still lingered in his mind.
我想我当时九岁。我开始琢磨，如果他们更好地了解我，意识到我是个多么可爱迷人的小男孩，他们会不会更喜欢我？然后又想，嘿，如果他们更喜欢我，会不会让他们不那么讨厌其他犹太人？我当时并没有意识到，但这些当然都是深刻的社会心理学问题。在布兰代斯大学，埃利奥特决定主修经济学。那是20世纪50年代，但他童年时期的大萧条岁月仍然挥之不去。
Surely, training in economics would allow him to figure out how to make a living. But his plans changed one day because of a date. One afternoon I was having a cup of coffee with a young woman, a fellow student who I was interested in romantically and so I was trying very hard to impress her in this conversation we were having at coffee. And suddenly she looks at her watch and says, oh my god, I'm going to be late for class. And I walked along with her to her class and she told me it was a class in introductory psychology and it was a large lecture class and I figured oh, maybe we can sit together in the back of the classroom and hold hands or something I got there and the class was being taught by some guy named Abraham Maslow. I had never heard of Abraham Maslow, I thought, you know, just another professor.
经济学方面的培训肯定能让他弄清楚如何谋生。但因为一次约会，他的计划改变了。一天下午，我正和一个年轻女子喝咖啡，她也是个学生，我对她很有浪漫的好感，所以我在我们喝咖啡时的这场谈话中竭力想给她留下深刻印象。突然，她看了一眼手表说：“哦天哪，我上课要迟到了。”我陪着她去上课，她告诉我这是一门心理学导论课，是一个有很多人听的大课。我想，哦，也许我们可以坐在教室后排一起手拉手什么的。我到了那里，这门课正由一个叫亚伯拉罕·马斯洛的家伙讲授。我从未听说过亚伯拉罕·马斯洛，我想，你知道的，不过又是个教授罢了。
And so I'm sitting in the back of the room with this young woman holding hands. And Maslow was talking about the psychology of prejudice. And as he was lecturing, I tuned in a little bit, and he was raising some of the very same questions that I had raised 10 years earlier when I was nine years old sitting on that curb stone, nursing a split lip and a bloody nose in reveria massachusetts. And so I thought, hey, this is interesting.
于是我跟这个年轻女子坐在房间后排手拉手。马斯洛正在讲授偏见的心理学。当他讲课时，我稍微听进去了一点，他提出的一些问题正是我10年前在马萨诸塞州里维尔坐在路边石上、处理着破裂的嘴唇和流血的鼻子的九岁时所提出的问题。所以我心想，嘿，这挺有意思的。
I let go of the girl's hand, and I started to take notes. And I lost the girl, but I gained a vocation, because I got so excited about what Maslow was talking about that the very next day I switched my major from economics to psychology within a few months I began working with Maslow and it eventually became a protégé of his and it changed my life. And it changed my life. Abraham Maslow went on to become one of the most famous psychologists ever. He's best known for his theory about a hierarchy of needs.
我松开女孩的手，开始做笔记。我失去了这个女孩，却收获了职业，因为我对马斯洛所讲的内容感到如此兴奋，以至于第二天我就把主修专业从经济学换成了心理学，在几个月内我开始与马斯洛合作，并最终成为了他的门徒，这改变了我的生活。这改变了我的生活。亚伯拉罕·马斯洛后来成为了有史以来最著名的心理学家之一。他最著名的是关于需求层次的理论。
The most basic need is the need we have for oxygen, for water, for food. And then we have needs that go a little beyond that need for safety a need for have to have a lodging that keeps us out of the rain and out of the weather. And then there's another level a need for self-respect the need to be esteemed by others a need for love. And it gradually it's kind of like in the shape of a pyramid, as they get higher and higher, I guess narrower and narrower, and ends with a need that he calls self-actualization, which is the highest place to be. And I've always thought about that as not really a place to be, a place to be, it's a process that never ends, and we become who we want to be by how we behave in crucial situations.
最基础的需求是我们对氧气、水、食物的需求。然后我们有一些稍微超越这些的需求——对安全的需求、对拥有一个能让我们避雨挡风的住所的需求。再往上一层是对自尊的需求、被他人尊重的需求、对爱的需求。渐渐地，它有点像金字塔的形状，越来越高，我想也越来越窄，最终以他所说的“自我实现”的需求告终，这是最高境界。我一直认为那其实不是一个要到达的终点，而是一个永无止境的过程，我们通过自己在关键情境中的行为来塑造我们想成为的人。
Psychology at this time was split between two groups. There were the Freudians who had lots of interesting theories about the mind and how experiences early in life shape our outlook on life. There were the Freudians who had lots of interesting theories about the mind and how experiences early in life shape our outlook on life. And then there were the Behaviourous, led by Fred Skinner, who dismissed the Freudians as unscientific. Forget about all that stuff inside people's heads they said, let's just measure how they behave.
当时的心理学分为两派。一派是弗洛伊德学派，他们对心灵以及生活早期的经历如何塑造我们的生活观有许多有趣的理论。一派是弗洛伊德学派，他们对心灵以及生活早期的经历如何塑造 our 生活观有许多有趣的理论。然后是以弗雷德·斯金纳为首的行为主义者，他们认为弗洛伊德学派是不科学的。他们说，忘掉人们头脑里那些东西吧，让我们只测量他们的行为。
In a range of experiments, the Behavi showed animal behavior was powerfully shaped or reinforced by rewards and punishments. Elliott loved Abraham Maslow and his humanistic theory of human nature, but he sensed that the older scholar was not really a scientist. The behaviorists had signed a rigor, but to Elliot they lacked so. Yes, humans are animals and human behavior can be shaped by incentives, but people are more complex than rats running through mazes to find food. As he started his PhD at Stanford, Elliot found himself drawn to a new professor at the school. He had a reputation for being mean, nasty, impatient, who was capable of devouring tender young graduate students like me for breakfast.
在一系列实验中，行为主义者表明动物的行为受到奖赏和惩罚的强力塑造或强化。埃利奥特热爱亚伯拉罕·马斯洛及其关于人性的本本主义理论，但他隐约觉得这位老学者并不是真正的科学家。行为主义者具备严谨性，但在埃利奥特看来，他们缺乏灵魂。是的，人类是动物，人类的行为可以被激励所塑造，但人类比在迷宫中寻找食物的老鼠要复杂得多。当他在斯坦福大学开始攻读博士学位时，埃利奥特发现自己被学校的一位新教授吸引了。他以刻薄、讨厌、不耐烦而闻名，能够把像我这样温柔年轻的研究生当早餐吃掉。
He was very difficult, but he also had the reputation for being a bit of a genius. So I signed up for Leon Festinger's course, and within a few weeks I learned that everything they said about him was true. He was a genius. He was very, very smart. It was a terrific seminar, very high level, but if you came into that seminar room, the least bit unprepared there was hell to pay, it was capable of embarrassing you in the worst possible way. One day he assigned a term paper, so I wrote this term paper in a few hours and handed it in. The next day I'm walking
他非常难相处，但他也以有点天才而闻名。所以我报名参加了利昂·费斯廷格的课程，几周内我就发现他们对他的评价都是真的。他是个天才。他非常非常聪明。这是一个非常棒的研讨会，水平很高，但如果你走进那个研讨室时哪怕有一点点准备不足，那可就要倒大霉了，他有能力以最糟糕的方式让你难堪。有一天他布置了一篇学期论文，所以我花了几小时写完并交了上去。第二天我路过
past his office, he called me in to his office and said, Aronson, come in here, I've walked into his office. And he took my turn paper, he stretched out his arm, held it between his thumb and forefinger, turned his head away and said, I believe this is yours. So with all the bravado, the false bravado, I could muster. I said, gee doctor, festing her, I guess you didn't like it very much. And he gave me a look that was, much. And he gave me a look that was I've never seen that look on anyone else before. It was a mixture of contempt and pity. He said, that's right. I didn't like it very much. Eliot re-read his paper with fresh eyes and realized it was poorly argued. So I went back home and for the next three days I reworked that paper and I reworked that paper and then I walked into Festing his office, put it on his desk and then I walked
他的办公室，他把我叫进办公室说：“阿伦森，进来。”我走进了他的办公室。他拿起我的学期论文，伸长胳膊，用大拇指和食指捏着它，把头转过去说：“我想这是你的。”于是，我拿出我能汇聚的所有虚张声势。我说：“天哪，费斯廷格博士，我想你可能不太喜欢它。”他给了我一个眼神，那是。他给了我一个眼神，那是 我以前从未在任何人身上见过那种眼神。那是蔑视与怜悯的混合体。他说：“没错。我确实不太喜欢。”埃利奥特用全新的目光重新阅读了自己的论文，发现它的论证很糟糕。所以我回了家，在接下来的三天里我重写了那篇论文，我重写了那篇论文，然后我走进费斯廷格的办公室，把它放在他的桌上，然后我走回
back to my own office and to his great, he must have dropped whatever he was doing and read the paper, because what he did, he came back into my office, put the paper in front of me, sat on the corner of my desk, put his hand on my shoulder, and said, now this is worth criticizing. This is worth criticizing, which doesn't sound like much, but what he was telling me with that gesture is that if you're willing to meet me halfway, if you're willing to work as hard as you possibly can, to make the thing you're doing as good as it possibly can be, he would give you everything he had.
了自己的办公室，令他大为赞赏的是，他一定放下手头的所有工作读了这篇论文，因为他做的是：他回到了我的办公室，把论文摆在我面前，坐在我桌子的边缘，把手搭在我的肩膀上说：“这篇才值得批判。”这篇才值得批判。这听起来可能不算什么，但通过这个手势他向我传达的是：如果你愿意与我相向而行，如果你愿意尽你所能努力工作，把你正在做的事情做到极致的好，他就会倾其所有。
And from that moment on, we became teacher and student. Within a few months, he began to treat me like a colleague was an incredible experience for me. Leon Festinger was on the concept of developing an important theory that would explain an extraordinary range of human behavior. Soon, he and Elliot were working on it together. It's a very simple theory with enormous ramifications. The basic theory is if a person holds an idea or an opinion that conflicts with some behavior that you yourself have done.
从那一刻起，我们成为了师生。几个月内，他开始像对待同事一样对待我，这对我来说是一次难以置信的体验。利昂·费斯廷格正致力于发展一个能够解释极其广泛的人类行为的重要理论。很快，他和埃利奥特就在一起研究它了。这是一个非常简单却有着巨大衍生影响的理论。基本理论是：如果一个人持有一个观点或看法，而这与你亲身做过的某种行为相冲突。
Two ideas are opinions that don't quite match, that may be the opposite of one another. You experience something called cognitive dissonance, which is a clash, and it acts as a negative drive state like extreme hunger or extreme thirst. You will do whatever you can to reduce that negative drive state and the way to reduce it is by finding a way to distort your own thinking so that those two ideas or events become closer and closer together, less disparate, less opposite from one another. Think about a kid who gets beaten up because he is Jewish. He cannot understand why older boys would hurt him. But then, a few years later,
两个观点或看法不太匹配，甚至可能完全相反。你就会体验到一种叫做“认知失调”的东西，这是一种冲突，它像极度饥饿或极度干渴一样，作为一种负面驱动状态发挥作用。你会不惜一切代价去减少这种负面驱动状态，而减少它的方式就是找到一种方法来扭曲你自己的思考，使这两个想法或事件变得越来越接近、越来越不那么迥异、越来越不那么对立。想想一个因为自己是犹太人而被痛打的孩子。他无法理解为什么大一点的男孩会伤害他。但随后，几年后，
the boy himself becomes a tormentor of other children. In that moment, to explain his own behavior to himself, to resolve his cognitive dissonance, he comes up with a self-justification. I want to make sure that they didn't include me with the group that was being bullied. In this telling, Elliot the bully isn't really a bully. He's just a frightened kid who's trying to protect himself from being harmed again. Elliot's father didn't want to think of himself as being an irresponsible husband who gambled away his family's well-being. So he came up with an explanation for why his business failed. It was the great depression. And we all do that as best we can. And it happens at
这个男孩自己却成了其他孩子的折磨者。那一刻，为了向自己解释自己的行为，为了解决他的认知失调，他想出了一个自我合理化的借口。我想确保他们没有把我归入被霸凌的群体中。这样说来，霸凌者埃利奥特其实并不是真正的霸凌者。他只是一个试图保护自己免受再次伤害的受惊吓的孩子。埃利奥特的父亲不想认为自己是一个不负责任、把家庭幸福拿去赌博的丈夫。因此，他为自己的生意为什么失败想出了一个解释。那是大萧条。我们所有人都在尽最大努力这样做。这发生在
an unconscious level, just below the usual level of consciousness that we walk around with, so that we are trying to make sense of the world. It really is a theory of sense-making. How can we make sense of the world that we can hold these two ideas? They seem to be the opposite of each other, but we find a way to make them fit. In one of the early experiments that Leon Festinger conducted, he looked at people's willingness to tell a lie in exchange for different sums of money. Tell me about that experiment, Elliot.
一个无意识的层面上，就在我们日常意识水平的下方，因此我们试图让这个世界变得合理。这确实是一个关于寻找意义的理论。我们如何才能理解这个世界，以至于我们能够同时持有这两个看似完全相反的观点，却能找到一种方法让它们契合？在利昂·费斯廷格进行早期的一项实验中，他考察了人们为了不同金额的金钱而说谎的意愿。埃利奥特，跟我讲讲那个实验吧。
What was the experiment aiming to do? What did it find? That to me is one of these single most important experiments ever done in social psychology. He puts people through a very, very boring task, turning a bunch of screws one-quartered turn to the right, and then turning back two-quarters of a turn to the left. Each subject's assignment to turn each of the wooden pegs a quarter turn to the right, then to start over and turn them again and again and again. Over and over and over again.
那个实验的目的是什么？它发现了什么？在我看来，这是社会心理学中做过的最最重要的实验之一。他让人们完成一个非常非常无聊的任务，把一堆螺丝向右转四分之一圈，然后再向左转回四分之一圈。每个被试的任务是将每一个木钉向右转四分之一圈，然后重新开始，一次又一次地转动它们。一遍又一遍又一遍。
Until the experimenter tells him to stop, it is the most boring and fatiguing task we could devise. The researcher then told the volunteers to tell someone in the next room that the task was very interesting. And he offers to pay the person in one condition, he pays them $1 in another condition, he pays them $20. So I'd like to offer you a $20 retainer and have you remain on court for us. Would that be alright? 20 hours?
直到实验人员叫停，这是我们能设计出的最无聊、最让人精疲力竭的任务。然后研究者让志愿者去告诉隔壁房间的人，这个任务非常有趣。他提出付钱给这个人，在一种情况下，他付一美元；在另一种情况下，他付二十美元。我想向你提供二十美元的报酬，请你为我们候命。这样行吗？二十个小时？
That is fine. We'd like to give you a dollar as sort of a retainer and have you remain on court with us. Would that be alright with you? Yes, that'll be alright. And the job is to convince the other person. Yeah, I just was in that experiment and it really is interesting. Well, we turned pegs and knobs the same way each time.
可以的。我们想给你一美元作为某种报酬，请你为我们候命。这样行吗？行，这可以的。而工作就是说服另一个人。对，我刚才做了那个实验，真的很有趣。嗯，我们每次都以相同的方式转动木钉和旋钮。
And that's about what it was, but it was very interesting. They gave us some pegs to turn and, well, I turned them for a while and it was a lot of fun. It was sort of interesting. I guess. Well, that's strange because a friend of mine took the experiment last week. I think it was the same experiment. And he said it was pretty miserable.
差不多就是这样，但非常有趣。他们给我们一些木钉去转，嗯，我转了一会儿，挺好玩的。挺有意思的。我猜是吧。嗯，这很奇怪，因为我的一个朋友上周也参加了这个实验。我想是同一个实验。他说这简直糟透了。
And that I should do everything I could to get out of it. Well, I think maybe a friend was wrong, perhaps it's a different experiment, because this was a lot of fun. It appeared to me as if we were a puzzle. We had a turn to start. After the study subjects lied about how interesting the experiment was to the person in the next room, Leon Festinger then asked the study subjects what they themselves thought of the original
而且我应该尽一切努力退出。嗯，我想也许我朋友弄错了，可能这是个不同的实验，因为这个真的很好玩。在我看来，我们就像是一个谜题。我们得开始转动。在研究对象对隔壁房间的人谎称实验有多么有趣之后，利昂·费斯廷格接着询问研究对象他们自己对最初那个
task. And what do you found that if you told the lie for $20, you didn't like the task very much. You thought it was boring, it was ugly, et cetera. I hated it. Did you enjoy working on the manual test? Well, it really wasn't too enjoyable. In fact, it was rather boring.
任务的看法。你发现了什么？如果你为了二十美元说谎，你其实并不怎么喜欢这个任务。你觉得它很无聊、很难看，等等。我讨厌它。你喜欢做这个手工测试吗？嗯，其实不是太好玩。事实上，相当无聊。
But if you were paid only $1, you actually liked the task in retrospect. So how much did you learn from this experiment? Well, at first I don't think I was learning it too much, but when I got into it, I think it was quite interesting. After a while it got better. Did you enjoy working on the manual test? Yes, I enjoyed it. Now what's interesting about this, as you can easily see, is it's the exact opposite of what Fred Skinner would have predicted.
但如果你只拿到了一美元，回想起来你其实挺喜欢这个任务的。那么你从这个实验中学到了多少？嗯，起当我并不觉得学到了太多，但当我深入其中时，我觉得相当有趣。过了一会儿变好了。你喜欢做这个手工测试吗？是的，我很喜欢。现在有趣的是，正如你很容易看出来的，这与弗雷德·斯金纳所预测的完全相反。
It's the opposite of reinforcement theory. Here is a task that's associated with a small reward, and you like it more than a task associated with a large reward? How could that possibly be? Well, the way it works, because we are cognitive animals, in the $20 condition, the people in that experiment sold their soul for $20, and it was worth it. They were paid well for telling that lie. They had no reason to justify it. I told a lie for $20. It was worth it. If you did it for only $1, you did it, but you felt bad about doing it, and you didn't receive much of reward for it, so there was no justification for doing it. So you have to say, well, you know, a task wasn't so bad, actually when I was turning those screws I was actually getting good exercise from my wrist, and that will improve my tennis game.
这与强化理论相反。这是一个与小奖励相关的任务，而你对它的喜爱程度竟然超过了与大奖励相关的任务？这怎么可能呢？嗯，它的运作方式是这样的，因为我们是有认知的动物，在二十万美元的条件下，那个实验中的人为了二十美元出卖了灵魂，这是值得的。他们因说谎而获得了一笔丰厚的报酬。他们没有理由为此进行合理化。我为了二十美元说谎了。这是值得的。如果你只为了一美元做这件事，你做了，但你对此感到糟糕，而且你没有因此得到多少奖励，所以没有任何做这件事的合理化理由。因此你不得不说：“嗯，你知道，这个任务其实也没那么糟，事实上当我转动那些螺丝时，我其实是在给手腕做很好的锻炼，这会提高我的网球水平。”
Or some other way of reducing distance to try to convince yourself that something that you would initially have found very dull actually had some virtue to it. So what you're saying is that when I do the task for 20 bucks, I know that I'm being paid to do something on pleasant but I'm being paid well, so I feel okay I'm taking getting the money, I don't like the task, but I'm gonna do it anyway. You're saying when I'm asked to lie, but I'm only given a dollar, I now have to tell myself, if I was telling myself the truth, I would have to say, not only did I sell my soul,
或者通过其他减少失调的方式，试图让自己相信一个你最初觉得非常枯燥的事情其实有其美德所在。所以你的意思是，当我为了二十块钱做这个任务时，我知道我是在拿钱做一件令人不愉快的事，但我报酬拿得很好，所以我感觉还好，我拿了钱，我不喜欢这个任务，但我还是会做。你是说当被要求说谎，却只拿到一美元时，我现在必须对自己说，如果我说的是实话，我不仅出卖了灵魂，
I sold my soul for only a dollar. Now, that just doesn't make me a bad person, it makes me a fool. And you're saying that produces cognitive dissonance. Absolutely. And you can see now why our whole educational system is wrong because we reward people for learning things. We give them an external reward, equivalent to the $20. We give them good grades or high praise for doing well
而且我只为了一美元就出卖了灵魂。这不仅让我成了一个坏人，还让我成了一个傻瓜。你这是说这会产生认知失调？绝对是的。你现在可以看到为什么我们整个教育体系都是错误的，因为我们通过奖励人们来让他们学习。我们给予他们外部奖励，相当于那二十美元。我们因为他们做得好而给予他们好成绩或高度赞扬
and things like that. What prevents people from doing is convincing themselves that they're learning about the geography of Indonesia because it's interesting in and of itself. They convince themselves I'm doing it in order to get a good grade. Who cares about the geography of Indonesia? And I think that is the great innovation that Leon Festinger produced for us.
诸如此类的事。阻碍人们的是什么呢？是说服自己去了解印度尼西亚的地理，因为这本身就很有趣。他们说服自己我这么做是为了得高分。谁在乎印度尼西亚的地理啊？我认为这是利昂·费斯廷格为我们带来的伟大创新。
It isn't that reward, reinforcement theory is wrong. It's that it's incomplete. That it does work. But there are situations and a great many of them in the real world where just the opposite happens. If you're underpaid for doing something, you will find something about that job that is inherently interesting in order to justify the fact that you're doing it for no external reward or for very little external reward. I want to draw your attention to something else that you've told me that I think is really interesting,
并不是说奖励、强化理论是错的。而是说它是不完整的。它的确起作用。但在现实世界中，有许多许多这样的情境，恰恰相反的事情发生了。如果你因做某事而报酬过低，你就会发现该工作的某些部分本身就很有趣，以此来证明你这样做是没有外部报酬或只有极少外部报酬的合理性。我想把你的注意力引向你曾跟我讲过的另一件我觉得非常有趣的事，
which is that you've had not one mentor here, but two mentors. You had Abraham, Mass, Leu and Leon Festinger. And first of all, it's very fortunate to have two mentors who are both giants of a field at the very formative stages of your career. So it's very fortunate. But these two people were completely unlike one another. And in fact, they didn't particularly like one another. Did you experience that as a form of cognitive dissonance? That's putting it mildly.
那就是你在这里不是有一位导师，而是有两位导师。你拥有亚伯拉罕·马斯洛和利昂·费斯廷格。首先，在你的职业生涯刚起步的形成阶段，能同时拥有两位该领域的泰斗作为导师，是非常幸运的。所以这非常幸运。但这两人完全不同。事实上，他们彼此并不怎么喜欢对方。你把这当作一种认知失调来体验吗？这话说得太轻描淡写了。
They hated each other. When I started to work with Leon and I actually had done a couple of experiments at Stanford that were really exciting to me, I went back east and while I was there I called on Maslow and we were having lunch and Maslow said, well who are you working with out there at Stanford? And I said, I'm working with this guy Leon Festinger and Maslow said, Festinger, that bastard, how can you stand him? And then I went back to Stanford and a few months later Leon and I are at a bar having a drink. And said, hey Elliot tell me how would you first get
他们互相憎恨。当我开始和利昂合作时，实际上我在斯坦福做过几个让我感到非常兴奋的实验，我回到了东海岸，在那儿时我拜访了马斯洛，我们在吃午饭，马斯洛说：“嗯，你在斯坦福跟谁一起工作？”我说：“我和斯坦福的这个叫利昂·费斯廷格的家伙一起工作。”马斯洛说：“费斯廷格，那个混蛋，你怎么能忍受他？”然后我回到了斯坦福，几个月后利昂和我正在酒吧喝一杯。他说：“嘿，埃利奥特，告诉我，你是怎么最初对心理学感兴趣的？”我说：“哦，我无意中走进了一场由亚伯拉罕·马斯洛主讲的讲座，他在我本科期间成了我的导师，那是……”我说：“马斯洛，哇，那个家伙的想法太糟了，甚至连‘错误’都算不上。”他所谓的“连错误都算不上”是指，你无法检验它们，根本无法证伪它们。我的两位导师，两个我无比热爱和尊敬的人，却互相憎恨。这确实最初给我带来了一点失调。但我后来意识到，某种程度上我成了一个能够弥合这两人之间鸿沟的人。
interested in psychology and I said oh I happened to wander into a lecture given by Abraham Maslow and he became my mentor as an undergraduate and that's the thing I said Maslow wow that guy's ideas are so bad, they're not even wrong. And by that, he meant, you can't test them, there's no way to disprove them. My two mentors, two guys I loved and respected enormously, who really hated each other. And that did cause me a little initial dissonance. But then I realized that I was in some way somebody who could bridge the gap between those two guys.
人们曾说我的研究实际上是费斯廷格和马斯洛的某种结合，无论其原因是什么，它产出了一些有趣的东西。总而言之，埃利奥特·阿伦森作为认知失调领域的奠基人之一，帮助发展了认知失调理论，部分原因是为了处理他关于自己两位导师的认知失调。真可谓研究即“我研”（研究自我）。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。作为一名学生，埃利奥特·阿伦森曾与两位心理学传奇人物合作。
And people have said that my own research really is a kind of a marriage between Festinger and Maslow and whatever was the cause of it it produced some interesting stuff. To summarize then, Elliot Aronson, one of the founders of the field of cognitive dissonance, helped develop the theory of cognitive dissonance in part to deal with his own cognitive dissonance about his two mentors. Talk about research really being me-search. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. As a student, Elliott Aronson worked with two legends of psychology.
亚伯拉罕·马斯洛是一位人本主义者，他提出人类具有需求层次。例如，当人们对安全的未满足需求存在时，这种基本需求就会掩盖更高层次的需求，比如对自尊的追求。利昂·费斯廷格是科学家中的科学家。他认为唯一值得讨论的观点是那些能够经受科学分析检验的观点。通过极具创造性的实验，他提出了认知失调理论——当我们脑海中的两个观念发生冲突时，我们所感受到的心理代价。
Abraham Maslow was a humanist, and he proposed that human beings have a hierarchy of needs. When people have unmet needs for safety, for example, that basic need overshadows higher needs, like the quest for self-respect. Leon Festinger was a scientist's scientist. He believed that the only ideas worth discussing were ones that could be subjected to scientific analysis. Using highly creative experiments, he came up with a theory of cognitive dissonance, the psychological toll we feel when two ideas in our heads clash with each other.
这两位资深科学家彼此厌恶。埃利奥特深爱着他们俩，他觉得建立他们思想之间的桥梁是自己的责任，尽管他无法弥合他们作为人的分歧。在埃利奥特早期的研究之一中，他回到了霸凌这一主题。他想了解为什么有些组织会容忍霸凌，以及它对受害者产生的影响。让我告诉你最初的假设及其原因。
The two senior scientists detested one another. Elliott, who loved them both, felt it was his responsibility to build a bridge between their ideas even if he could not bridge their differences as people. In one of Eliot's earlier studies, he returned to the topic of bullying. He wanted to understand why bullying is tolerated in some organizations and the effects it has on victims. Let me tell you the first to hypothesis and the reason for it.
如果你为某事努力工作，或者为了加入某个兄弟会而经历了严酷的入会仪式，或者为了加入海军陆战队而经历了严酷的基础训练，或者历经艰难险阻去实现某事，那么关于你所实现之事的任何负面看法，都与你为了得到它而付出巨大努力、为此付出沉重代价的事实相矛盾。关于那个事物的任何负面看法，都会让人尴尬地想到“我为了那个东西做了那么多工作”。因此，你通过淡化负面事物来减少失调
If you work hard for something, or go through a severe initiation in order to get into a fraternity for example, or go through severe basic training in order to get into the Marine Corps, or go through Helen Highwater in order to achieve something, anything negative about the thing you have achieved is dissonant with the fact that you worked so hard to get it, that you paid a lot for it to get that thing. Anything negative about that thing is embarrassing to think I did all that work for that. So you reduce the dissonance by downplaying the negative things
并提升任何正面事物。这就是霸凌在如此多的机构中持续存在的原因吗？如果你为了被接纳而经历了一段可怕的虐新期，你现在是否会产生一种反常的、更深的对机构的忠诚，以减少你的认知失调？反过来，随着你在机构中职位晋升，你是否会让
about the thing that you gained and upgrading any positive things. Was this why bullying persisted at so many institutions? If you went through a terrible hazing period in order to be accepted, would you now proversely feel deeper loyalty to the institution in order to reduce your cognitive dissonance? And in turn, as you ascended the ranks at the institution, would you subject
新来者经受你曾遭受的同种虐新，并开始将之视为一项应当尊重的传统？这正是亚伯拉罕·马斯洛会热爱的那种人本主义洞见，但这项研究运用了利昂·费斯廷格的方法。因此，在这个实验中，我们招募志愿者参加一个关于性心理学的集体讨论。然后我们让这些自愿前来的人进来，我们说：“为了加入这个小组，因为我们要确保你们能够在小组里畅所欲言，我们必须让你们通过一个小型的入会实验，这能向我们证明你们有能力
newcomers to the same kind of hazing that you suffered and come to see it as a tradition to be honored? It was the kind of humanistic insight Abraham Maslow would have loved, but the study deployed Leon Festinger's methods. So in this experiment, we got people to volunteer to join a group discussion on the psychology of sex. We then had the people who volunteered, they came in and we said in order to join this group because we want to make sure that you're able to talk freely in the group, we have to put you through a little initiation experiment that will show us that you're capable of
做到这一点。”在一种条件下，这是严酷入会条件。他们阅读了一串极其肮脏的词汇，那种你绝不想听到你母亲说出口的脏话，肮脏的词汇，比如你可能会在男厕所的墙上乱涂乱画看到的词。在温和入会条件下，
doing this. And in one condition, this was the severe initiation condition. They read a list of really filthy words, the kind of words that you wouldn't want your mother to hear you say, dirty words, like words you might see squal'd on a bathroom wall in a men's room. And in this mild initiation condition,
我们让他们阅读一串字典里的词，比如在严酷条件中出现的F开头的词，他们读的是诸如此类的词。所以它们是可以用于混合性别场合的得体词汇，但仍然会稍微令人尴尬。然后还有第三种条件，即根本没有提到任何测试或入会程序。所以我们有严酷入会、温和入会、
we had them read a list of dictionary words, like instead of the F word, which was in the severe condition, they read something like sexual intercourse, and things of that sort. So they were okay words that you could use in mixed company, but it still would be mildly embarrassing. And then there was a third condition where there was no talk of any kind of test or initiation procedure. So we had a severe initiation, a mild initiation,
我们让他们读一份字典里的词汇清单，比如代替在严重组中出现的F开头的粗口，他们读的是类似性交之类的话题。所以这些词是在公共场合也能说、但多少还是会让人觉得有点尴尬的词。然后还有第三种情况，就是完全不提及任何测试或入会程序。所以我们有严格的入会，有温和的入会，
and a zero initiation condition. Elliot then had the volunteers join the group and listen in on a discussion about sex. He arranged for the discussion to be mind-numbingly boring. Later, Elliott and his colleagues interviewed the volunteers and asked them if they found the discussion interesting. And we found out that those who went through the severe initiation liked the group a lot better than those in the mild condition, who liked it a little better than those in the no initiation condition. Volunteers who were put through the difficult initiation didn't want to tell themselves that
并设定了一个零启动条件。随后，埃利奥特让志愿者加入小组，并旁听一场关于性的讨论。他刻意把这场讨论安排得极度无聊。后来，埃利奥特和他的同事们采访了志愿者，询问他们是否觉得这场讨论有趣。结果我们发现，那些经历过严厉启动条件的人，比那些处于温和启动条件的人要喜欢这个小组得多；而温和条件组的人，又比那些没有启动条件的人稍微更喜欢这个小组。那些经历了困难启动的志愿者，不愿意告诉自己
they had endured a lot of embarrassment in order to join a boring group. So they rationalized away all the negatives. When I interviewed them and I said, you really did like boring group. So they rationalized away all the negatives. When I interviewed them and I said, you really did like the group, those in the severe condition. You really did like the group. Didn't you notice that, you know, like some people didn't do the reading? Didn't that strike you as being wrong? And the people in the severe condition would say things like, I wish he had done the reading, but how good of him, how honest of him, to immediately say, I didn't do the reading this time,
为了加入一个无聊的小组，他们忍受了极大的尴尬。因此，他们把所有的负面因素都合理化了。当我采访他们并对他们说：“你们其实真的挺喜欢这个无聊的小组的。”那些处于严厉条件下的受访者回答：“你们确实很喜欢这个小组，难道你们没注意到，比如有些人根本没有做阅读作业吗？这难道不让你觉得有问题吗？”而处于严厉条件组的人会说这样的话：“我希望他当时做了阅读，但他能立刻承认‘我这次没做阅读’，他这是多么好、多么诚实啊，
I wasn't able to do it, I'm really happy to be in a group with a person like that, whereas the people in the mild condition or in the no initiation condition would say things like, I don't want to be in a group with guys who don't do their obligation and that's how dissonance reduction works. That the human mind is a very interesting thing. Leon Festinga theorized that cognitive dissonance arises when two thoughts contradict one another. The thoughts are inconsistent. You need to resolve that inconsistency.
我没能完成，我真的很高兴能和这样的人在一个小组里。”相比之下，那些处于温和条件组或没有启动条件组的人会说：“我可不想和那些不履行义务的家伙在一个小组里。”这就是认知失调发挥作用的方式。人类的大脑是一个非常有趣的东西。莱昂·费斯廷格提出理论认为，当两个想法相互矛盾时，认知失调就会产生。这些想法是不一致的。你需要解决这种不一致。
Elliot agreed, but he took Abraham Maslow's concept that we want to think highly of ourselves and married that idea to the theory of cognitive dissonance. If you take that experiment I did where people who work hard to get into a group or go through an embarrassing initiation to get into the group will like that group better. When can talk about it in terms of pure cognition. I worked hard to get into a group. The group turned out to be lousy. Those are two dissonant cognitions, those are like any cognition. But the way I would reframe it now is I am a smart sensible person and I worked hard to get into a group that turned out to be really lousy. Okay? Smart sensible people do not work hard to get into a lousy group.
埃利奥特表示赞同，但他采用了亚伯拉罕·马斯洛的概念，即我们渴望对自我有很高的评价，并将这一观点与认知失调理论结合了起来。如果你拿我做的那个实验来看：人们为了加入一个小组而付出艰辛的努力，或者为了加入小组而经历令人尴尬的启动仪式，他们就会更喜欢那个小组。我们可以从纯认知的角度来谈论它。我努力加入了小组。结果小组表现很糟糕。这是两个不和谐的认知，它们就像任何认知一样。但我现在会这样重新构建它：我是一个聪明、明智的人，我努力加入了一个结果实际上很糟糕的小组。对吧？聪明、明智的人是不会努力加入一个糟糕的小组的。
Bringing in the self-concept makes it clearer what we're predicting. And what people have said about my thinking in terms of the self-concept is that I converted cognitive distance theory into a theory about conflicting attitudes, into a theory about about conflicting attitudes into a theory about a behavior or an attitude that conflicts with a person conception of himself. Eliot writes, man likes to think of himself as a rational animal. However, it is more true that man is a rationalizing animal than he attempts to appear reasonable to himself and others. It was obvious how self-justification could produce harms, but perhaps channeling Abraham Maslow's humanistic outlook,
引入自我概念使得我们的预测更加清晰。人们对于我从自我概念角度进行的思考有过这样的评价：我把认知失调理论转化为了一个关于冲突态度的理论，转化为一个关于行为或态度与一个人对自己的看法发生冲突的理论。埃利奥特写道，人类喜欢把自己想象成理性的动物。然而，更真实的情况是，人类是一种将行为合理化的动物，他试图在自己和他人面前显得合理。自我合理化会产生危害，这是显而易见的，但也许正是借用了亚伯拉罕·马斯洛的人本主义视角，
Elliott began to ask whether the human propensity for self-justification could also be used for good. While teaching at the University of Texas at Austin, the local public school district asked for his help in improving the performance of students. It turned out that in Austin, like great many American cities, was residentially segregated.
埃利奥特开始思考，人类倾向于自我合理化的习性是否也可以被用于善途。当他在德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校教书时，当地的公立学区请求他帮忙改善学生的表现。结果发现，在奥斯汀，和许多美国城市一样，居住区是处于隔离状态的。
And when the classrooms were desegregated, the black and Mexican-American students were bust into the white neighborhoods for the first time. The schools in the minority sections of town in Austin were understaffed, underfunded. They didn't have all the goodies, all the niceties that the schools in the richer sections of town had. So that when school desegregation occurred,
当教室取消种族隔离时，黑人和墨西哥裔学生首次被用校车送到白人社区。奥斯汀少数族裔居住区的学校人手不足、资金短缺。它们没有那些富裕社区学校所拥有的各种好东西和好条件。因此，当学校取消种族隔离时，
if you take say the fifth grade, the white students were reading at a fifth and sixth grade level, whereas the black students for the most part and Mexican American students were reading at a fifth and sixth grade level, whereas the black students for the most part and Mexican American students were reading at only the fourth grade level. So what we saw in these classrooms was a highly competitive situation where the black and brown kids were guaranteed to lose because they were under prepared and they were also under confident. Students were trying to outdo one another and the black and brown kids could see themselves
如果你以五年级为例，白人学生的阅读水平达到了五年级和六年级的水准，而黑人学生和墨西哥裔学生在很大程度上……而黑人学生和墨西哥裔学生在很大程度上只有四年级的阅读水平。因此，我们在这些课堂上看到的是一种高度竞争的局面，黑人与棕色人种的孩子注定会失败，因为他们准备不足，而且也缺乏自信。学生们试图超越彼此，黑人与棕色人种的孩子能够看到自己
falling behind. Was there a way for students to feel the same camaraderie that members of a basketball team feel for each other? Elliot thought back to an experiment run by two of his students, John Jekker and David Landy. They induced cognitive dissonance and volunteers by asking them to do a favor for someone they didn't like. Afterwards the volunteers actually liked the person more.
正在落后。有没有一种方法能让学生感受到篮球队员之间那种同甘共苦的战友情谊？埃利奥特回想起他的两个学生约翰·杰克尔（John Jekker）和大卫·兰迪（David Landy）所做的一个实验。他们通过要求志愿者帮一个他们不喜欢的人一个忙，来诱发志愿者的认知失调。事后，志愿者实际上更喜欢那个人了。
Why would this happen? The very act of doing a favor for someone implies you like them. When you do a favor for someone you don't like, cognitive dissonance kicks in and encourages you to like the person. Elliot used this idea to create what he called the jigsaw classroom. Take something like in social studies,
为什么会这样？帮别人忙这一行为本身就暗示着你喜欢他们。当你去帮一个你不喜欢的人时，认知失调就会发挥作用，促使你去喜欢这个人。埃利奥特利用这个想法创造了他所谓的“拼图课堂”。以社会科为例，
the topic of the day was lives of great Americans and they were studying the life of Eleanor Roosevelt. So we broke the classroom down into five person groups, and we rewrote a short biography of Eleanor Roosevelt into five distinct paragraphs. In each group, each student has one paragraph and one paragraph only to learn and to learn it well, to read it over several times and to be prepared to teach it to the other students in their group. The group is as diverse as we can make it and they're trying to teach it to each other. What's really interesting about that is they're all pulling together, they're really trying hard.
当天的课题是伟大美国人的生平，他们正在研究埃莉诺·罗斯福的一生。于是我们将课堂分成五人一组，并将埃莉诺·罗斯福的一篇简短传记改写成五个不同的段落。在每个小组中，每个学生只有也只需要学习一个段落，并且要把它学好，反复阅读，并准备好教给自己小组里的其他学生。小组的组成尽可能多元化，他们正试图互相教学。真正有趣的是，他们都在齐心协力，真的在努力。
It didn't stand out that way. So if Carlos, a young Mexican American student, English is his second language. He speaks it all right, but he speaks with an accent. And when he's giving his report, he's hesitating a little and stumbling a little and let's say one of the other students in his group, Soda makes fun of him. The teacher can intervene at that point.
情况并非如此。因此，如果卡洛斯是一个年轻的墨西哥裔学生，英语是他的第二语言。他说得还可以，但带着口音。当他在做报告时，他有点犹豫，也有点结巴，假设他小组里的另一个学生苏打（Soda）取笑了。老师可以在那个时候进行干预。
Teachers moving from group to group to remind them, hey, it might be fun for you to make fun of Carlos, but you really have to learn about Eleanor Roosevelt's middle years and the test is going to be in 15 minutes. So what she's saying is, it's a different kind of game. It might be a good idea to heckle people if you're in a highly competitive situation, like the usual classroom situation, but if you heckle one of your teammates, then you're missing out on the opportunity to learn what is in Carlos's head
老师在各个小组之间走动，提醒他们：“嘿，取笑卡洛斯对你们来说可能挺好玩，但你们真的必须了解埃莉诺·罗斯福的中年生活，15分钟后就要考试了。”所以她想表达的是，这是另一种游戏。如果你身处高度竞争的环境中，比如平常的课堂环境，起哄嘲弄别人或许是个好主意；但如果你起哄嘲弄你的队友，那你就会失去了解卡洛斯脑海中所想的机会，
and which he's trying to convey to you. And that's exactly what happened. See, I'm a child who has been taught negative stereotypes about students from another race. Now I find that in order to get ahead myself, I need to collaborate with one of those students. This situation produces cognitive dissonance. Why am I collaborating with someone I dislike? To resolve that uncomfortable state, just as the study about doing favors for someone
而这些正是他试图向你传达的。事实也正是如此。你看，我是一个从小被灌输了关于其他种族学生负面刻板印象的孩子。现在我发现，为了让我自己取得进步，我需要与其中一名学生合作。这种局面产生了认知失调。我为什么要和一个我不喜欢的人合作？为了消除那种不舒服的状态，就像关于“帮一个你不喜欢的
you don't like had shown, I revise my negative views. The Austin Public School District started implementing the Jigsaw classroom. Elliott analyzed the data to see if it worked. The end result is spectacular. We printed teachers who were using Jigsaw against teachers in the system who was doing the same material in a traditional way and what we found is kids in the jigsaw group liked going to school better they loved learning that stuff better absenteeism went down to a greater extent they did better on objective
人”的研究显示的那样，我修正了我的负面看法。奥斯汀公立学区开始推行拼图课堂。埃利奥特对数据进行了分析，以看看它是否奏效。最终的结果非常惊人。我们将使用拼图教学法的老师与学区内采用传统方法教授相同材料的老师进行了对比，结果我们发现，拼图小组的孩子更喜欢上学，他们更热爱学习那些内容，旷课率大幅下降，他们在客观考试中
exams on that material better than students learning it in a traditional way. Students liked each other better. Prejudice was far down. Self-esteem of minority kids improved enormously. And in the playground, in schools that were using Jigsaw, there was much more co-mingling when students had a choice as to who to chat with. Much more integration.
对该材料的掌握程度也比用传统方法学习的学生更好。学生们彼此更加喜欢对方。偏见大幅减少。少数族裔孩子的自尊心得到了极大的提升。在那些使用拼图教学法的学校的操场上，当学生们可以自由选择和谁聊天时，会有更多的混合交往，融合度大大提高。
It was a phenomenal experiment. In time, lots of schools began implementing Elliott's idea of a Jigsaw classroom. Teachers began telling Eliot that they were not only seeing academic benefits but social and emotional benefits from deploying cognitive dissonance in this fashion. Eliot remembers one teacher from the South Bronx. Well, about a year earlier I had done a workshop in the South Bronx for teachers, and I trained them to use Jigsaw. The South Bronx was a really difficult place, as you may know it, but the teachers who came
这是一个了不起的实验。随着时间的推移，许多学校开始推行埃利奥特的拼图课堂理念。老师们开始告诉埃利奥特，通过这种方式运用认知失调，他们不仅看到了学术上的益处，还看到了社交和情感上的益处。埃利奥特记得南布朗克斯的一位老师。嗯，大约一年前，我在南布朗克斯为老师们办过一个工作坊，我培训他们使用拼图教学法。南布朗克斯是一个非常艰难的地方，正如你可能知道的那样，但是来参加
to this Jigsaw workshop were terrific. They were very motivated, and about seven or eight months after that workshop, I got a call from a teacher and she says, Dr. Aaron, I have to tell you the story. You're really gonna like this. I took my kids on a field trip to the Whitney Museum. Now, the Whitney Museum is only like a 20, 25 minute subway ride from the South Bronx.
这个拼图工作坊的老师们非常棒。他们动力十足。大约在那个工作坊结束七八个月后，我接到了一位老师的电话，她说：“埃伦博士，我得给你讲个故事。你一定会喜欢的。我带着我的孩子们去惠特尼博物馆进行了一次实地考察。现在，惠特尼博物馆距离南布朗克斯只有大约20、25分钟的地铁车程。”
A lot of those kids had never been to a museum before. They go into the museum and she stops them in front of a painting by a artist named Archie Old Gorky of a woman and a child. She gets them to look at that painting and really look at it. And then she has a book with her about Gorky's life. And in that book is a photograph of Gorky and his mother just a few months before she died prematurely when Gorky was a boy.
许多孩子以前从未去过博物馆。他们走进博物馆，老师把他们带到一幅由艺术家阿尔希尔·戈尔基（Archie Old Gorky）创作的画作前，画上是一个妇女和一个孩子。她让他们看着这幅画，真正地去端详它。然后她随身带了一本关于戈尔基生平的书。在那本书里，有一张戈尔基和母亲的照片，拍摄于她过早去世前几个月，当时戈尔基还是个男孩。
And she asked them, why do you suppose she said, that he went to the trouble of making a painting when he already had the photographs? It's a wonderful question. One student says, well, the painting is bigger. Another student says, well, the photograph is only in black and white,
她问他们：“你们觉得，”她说道，“他既然已经有了照片，为什么还要费心思去画一幅画呢？”这是一个绝妙的问题。一个学生说：“嗯，画更大一些。”另一个学生说：“嗯，照片只有黑白的，
and the picture was in color. Then she said, one of the kids, Willie Johnson, who he's been in my class all year, he never, ever said a word in class extremely shy. And his own mother had died a few months earlier of a drug overdose. He pointed to a thing in the portrait where you'll see that the mother's hands, he painted it in a kind of an idealized way. They don't look, there are no fingers. It looks like she's even wearing like white fuzzy mittens. And Willie Johnson called everybody's attention to the way Gorky painted his mother's hands and said, maybe he remembered his mother's hands as being so soft like cotton. hands as being so soft like cotton. And so he wanted to paint the hands that way. I didn't show up that way in the photograph, but in his mind, he caught that into the painting.
而画是彩色的。”然后她说，其中一个孩子威利·约翰逊（Willie Johnson）——他一整年都在我的班里，在课堂上从来没说过一句话，极其害羞。而且就在几个月前，他自己的母亲刚刚因为吸毒过量而去世——他指着肖像中的一个地方，在那里你会看到母亲的手，他是用一种理想化的方式画的。它们看起来不像，没有手指。看起来她甚至戴着白色毛茸茸的手套。威利·约翰逊把所有人的注意力吸引到戈尔基画他母亲双手的方式上，并说：“也许在他的记忆里，他母亲的手就像棉花一样柔软。所以他想把手画成那样。照片上没有显示出来，但在他的脑海里，他把那种感觉捕捉到了画中。”
And then the teacher said to me on the phone, most aggressive kid in the class came over to where Willie Johnson was standing and put his arm around his shoulders. And then the whole group came together and kind of spontaneously, in kind of a group hug. That's the kind of thing that the chicks are classroom allows to happen. When kids begin to look at each other, begin to empathize with each other, become motivated to see the best in each other rather than the worst, you're going to get things like that where a kid can express his feelings and it rebounds back into the classroom as a whole. In part two of our story, in our next episode, we follow Elliot as he uses cognitive dissonance to fight the AIDS epidemic and to help people stick to their resolutions. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
然后这位老师在电话里告诉我：“班里最富攻击性的孩子走到威利·约翰逊站着的地方，把手臂搭在他的肩膀上。接着，整个小组聚拢过来，以一种近乎自发的方式，进行了一场集体拥抱。”这就是拼图课堂能够促成的成果。当孩子们开始注视彼此、开始对彼此产生共情、被激发出去发现彼此最好的一面而不是最坏的一面时，你就会得到这样的结果：一个孩子可以表达他的情感，并反哺到整个班级。在我们的故事第二部分，也就是下一集中，我们将跟随埃利奥特，看他如何利用认知失调来对抗艾滋病流行，并帮助人们坚持他们的决心。《Hidden Brain》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。
Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Alice Zhang. Alice works at Apple Podcasts and she played a key role in the development of artwork for our new podcast subscription Hidden Brain Plus. Alice has a great eye for visual materials and the sort of can-do attitude that helps to move complex projects forward.
我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德里克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《Hidden Brain》的执行主编。我们本周的无名英雄是张爱丽丝（Alice Zhang）。爱丽丝在 Apple Podcasts 工作，她在我们全新播客订阅服务 Hidden Brain Plus 的封面和视觉艺术开发中发挥了关键作用。爱丽丝对视觉材料有着极佳的审美，并具备那种推动复杂项目向前发展的实干精神。
Thank you for all of your help, Alice. If you haven't yet given Hidden Brain Plus a try, it's where you'll find exclusive episodes featuring even more of the insights and ideas that we feature on the show. It's also where we'll share conversations with some of our most popular researchers who want to answer your questions on topics ranging from aging to self-doubt. You can find Hidden Brain Plus by searching for our show in the Apple Podcasts app or at apple.co slash hidden brain. Your subscription helps to fund our work and we're truly grateful for your support.
感谢你提供的所有帮助，爱丽丝。如果你还没有尝试过 Hidden Brain Plus，那里的独家单集将为你提供更多我们在节目中呈现的深刻见解与理念。我们还将在那里分享与一些最受欢迎的研究人员的对话，他们将解答你从衰老到自我怀疑等各种主题的问题。你可以在 Apple Podcasts 应用中搜索我们的节目，或者访问 apple.co/hidden brain 来找到 Hidden Brain Plus。你的订阅为我们的工作提供了资金支持，我们对你的支持深表感激。
I'm Shankar Vidantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。回头见。此剧集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。